so ally the men want to know where can  they find a woman a woman like you  oh i mean i'm a statistical anomaly but  for the most part you can find good  wholesome women away from the cities and  in the country especially if they come  from a two-parent household is there  like places they can look yeah the  entire midwest all that all that so do  you think like like churches like what  like what like specific places can they  go to to meet women  church is a complicated thing because  it's produced a lot of beta type males  but i would say that there are feminine  women in churches have to be careful if  they're not delusional okay okay